[Music]
this is a new episode of congratulations
crazy
oh dude somebody asked me somebody asked
me in the comments they were [ __ ]
they said why do you always keep your
mouth open when you're doing the when
you're doing the intro [ __ ] why do you
keep the mouth open when the [ __ ]
congratulations theme song plays
because i
[ __ ] wanted a dude because i wanted a
dude because that's the way it has to be
that's my [ __ ] destiny dude
yes
and you don't go hard or go home you go
medium and sometimes stay out i got that
[ __ ] merch on and i'm a coach baby
dude i'm a coach
[Music]
hell yeah i'm from kentucky
i'm a coach from kentucky and i'll tell
you what dude
look at that man that college blue and
yellow or something
oh [ __ ] yeah dude i feel good i put this
hat on today and calvin had a hat and he
had to use his hat and it was so cute we
love it man
we love we love it he got a hat dude he
has a hat and he loves garbage garbage
trucks
and
he loves them so much
and he call he says hatton hatton hatton
about everything that he doesn't know
what it is but garbage truck is the
number one thing that he says hadn't
about and when he hears
the garbage truck he goes
and he goes hidden and we go yeah let's
go he says hat manhattan so i got him a
[ __ ] hat oh i got a picture of it
i'll just put it up right here but i got
him a hat that says garbage day best day
and it's got a hatton in the middle so
dude who's a good dad [ __ ] me
i'm a good dad so we keep it 80s we keep
it real 80s i've got to [ __ ]
go medium or and sometimes stay out sure
merch on get at my website chrisley.com
and we keep it real ladies dude i'm
sorry i'm sorry 70s guys but we keep it
real ladies
i'm sorry
oh and dude people were like what are
you gonna work i was on twitch earlier
come on down to flex avenue we all lived
there we all lived there when you're on
my twitch flex avenue and i was just
chatting you know i was doing some irl
streaming and it's fine but that's what
i do i'm a twitcher now okay and i was
on there and i was talking to someone
was commenting what are you gonna work
out today dude and i took the day off
strong guys all over the country like
this sheesh
i didn't work out the hips i didn't work
out the knees i didn't work out the
[ __ ] i didn't work out the the biceps
or the [ __ ] back it's still nice
didn't work it out today strong guys all
over the nation like yeesh
whoo
but get a load of this strong guys i'm
working out tomorrow i'm sorry strong
guys
anyway let me take it down a notch dude
because sometimes we fire on all
syllables but i just want to get like
real with you guys man
for no reason i got sad today
no reason no reason at all and i know
that sounds funny after all the [ __ ] i
was saying about sorry strong guys and
how i [ __ ] i'm a coach but yeah i was
sad man i woke up fine
and it was all good everything was fine
returned the rental car because i
finally got my freaking car back dude
i'm mormon i'm trying to [ __ ] be
better at that
um
get my freaking car back and dude uh we
returned it and then i came back home
and then just started getting sad man
for no [ __ ] reason you ever get sad
for no apparent reason dude it sucks so
much
but it really does though i did the
jeremy renner's thing but it really does
dude it sucks man and i couldn't shake
it i went out to get some coffee and i
[ __ ]
you know that's what i do man i drank
another uh four shots over ice and i you
know it was it was uh and then i kind of
shook out the nerves i came home and and
crystal was like are you still sad and i
was like
i don't know i'm okay and i was like i
don't know how i'm gonna get in [ __ ]
podcast mode because you know i your
boy's gotta get in [ __ ] podcast mode
if you're gonna do a podcast but then i
was like maybe i don't have to get in
podcast mode to do a podcast
right maybe i can just chill maybe i
don't have to be [ __ ] on all the time
i don't and in fact i don't want to be
on all the time i want to be me i went
back to the thing i was learning in
therapy when i was
when i was going to uh i told my
therapist and there's a clip of it on
there's a clip of it on the more
crystallia
youtube channel it's a new new channel i
have more crystallia you can go go click
on it and subscribe all that [ __ ] but i
was talking about uh cr it's called
crystallia cries of therapy that's what
it was it was from a
previous podcast and i
i was talking about how dude i used to
walk into a room and how people [ __ ]
i just assumed people hated me and so i
would try to win them over by being
funny i would assume that they didn't
like me and i would be like here we go
let's just make fun of them make fun of
myself a little self-deprecating humor
and like just kill them with kindness
and have a good time and pretty soon
they'll end up liking me and i can do
that because i've done that with rooms
all over the country dude
and that's just so much work man maybe
they just [ __ ] like
somebody do you know what i'm saying
maybe they just hope for the best in
somebody but i had always had a thought
like oh yeah maybe they saw me in this
one show or one movie or my stand-up and
they [ __ ] hate me and even before
that i was like maybe they just don't
like me at all
you know
or maybe they just don't like a guy that
looks like me or they just don't like
people the defense is up so i gotta work
but i don't you don't have to dude and
in 41 now and i should have learned that
earlier and i don't want calvin to feel
that way you know my son
um but uh so maybe that's it man like
you guys rock with me man you guys have
been here and if you're listening you've
been listening you know what i'm talking
about and if you've been listening then
you rock with me and and i rock with you
dude
and uh if you rock with me
then i feel like
that's the key word is me you know i
don't always have to be on so uh i was
like i'm gonna do the podcast anyway and
i'm doing the podcast anyway and yes
still i'm doing the podcast anyway and
maybe i'm not in podcast mode maybe i'll
get to podcast mode maybe i won't maybe
this podcast will be a breath of fresh
air maybe it'll be a [ __ ]
dramatization maybe it won't maybe it'll
be [ __ ]
regular [ __ ] like a documentary and then
maybe it'll [ __ ] move on over to some
sorry strong guys feeling you know some
sorry strong guys attitude
but i'm not gonna fake it dude i'm not
gonna fake it
i'm not gonna fake it because you guys
know me man
you guys don't know me but you got you
know when i
when i talk
you can kind of feel me you know
especially if you've heard like i don't
know eight or nine episodes
so i just want to [ __ ] chill man and
i want to talk about the the things dude
i i've been really actually connecting
with um
i'm really actually connecting with uh
calvin a lot lately and i don't know
what it is he's tall dude he's uh
he's tall he's like uh 75th percentile
of tallness
and um and that's cool that he's tall
and i love him and he was
he does this thing now where he goes
like he says
where i say
who's who's dada and i thought like that
was gonna be like he was gonna like
point to me or whatever he just goes
and i'm just like this [ __ ]
i say who's that that is ant and i say
i'm that guy and he says
so it's very cute and that [ __ ] makes
my heart
blow up
um
it's just great man
i posted a picture of him the other day
and you know people are really cool
about like
you know when i post pictures of me and
my kid and [ __ ]
and uh
i don't know man i used to think about
like i wanted to keep that side of my
life private
you know when i first started this
podcast i started
with
i don't know why i'm doing this podcast
because i don't want you to know more
about me i want you to know less about
me like the good actors and the good
[ __ ] movie stars and [ __ ] are
the ones that you don't know much about
and i realized like being a comedian and
and like opening up to you guys it's
been kind of cathartic and it's been
good and it's been freeing and you know
i don't really have the hesitation that
i had before
um
posting calvin
or parts of my real life you know like
kristen and [ __ ] um
and i posted a pic the other day and
somebody got somebody you know everybody
was so nice and one guy was said
something like oh man enough of this
it's become a dad page
and uh he's like i'm out of here and he
unfollowed me on instagram he said
i'm out and unfollowed me or whatever
and i i i didn't feel any sort of like
way about it and i was like man this is
good like this would have pissed me off
like a year ago or something or two
years ago and i feel like it's like
whatever dude i don't give a [ __ ] about
that and then i look under my under that
comment and it's and there's a comment
from my mom ellie delia in all caps bye
i'm like ma
trying to be a better person working on
myself
so i can become a whole person and
here's my [ __ ] mom just laying down
the law in all caps bye
at least you know where i got it
um
jokes
but yeah no i don't know man
i [ __ ] i'm feeling i'm feeling okay i
was uh i was uh
i was uh
i was upset earlier and i'm feeling good
now of course i got postmates and here's
the other thing dude
i got the post i got postmates again i
usually try to get [ __ ] uber eats
because postmates is all like postmates
are just like what do you want burger
okay cool bringing you spaghetti
well you want tacos sounds good bring in
your pork loin
that's postmates
what you got what you got in the kitchen
blindfold me i'll throw something in the
bag
that's postmates
so i got postmates and sure enough i
ordered a salmon with a side of veggies
because your boy tries to be [ __ ]
lean as [ __ ] you know i'm 41 i'm not
getting any thinner unless i try
you see guys they get bloated and [ __ ]
when they get older it's not even their
fault they're just chilling you know i
don't drink alcohol you see guys have
one drink a week and all of a sudden
they puff out like a goddamn michelin
man so i'm like trying to watch my
weight and guess what they brought me
[ __ ]
uh
uh salmon and mashed potatoes dude you
know how hard first of all i don't like
mashed potatoes
but our friend was here and she was like
dude these mashed potatoes are great
because she got the mashed potatoes on
purpose and i was like yeah and i tasted
them they were so good dude and i don't
even really prefer mashed potatoes you
know how hard it is to not eat the good
mashed potatoes when they're on a plate
i ate some of them but not many and then
i remembered that i had a uh [ __ ] uh
a chicken bowl in the fridge from
earlier because i was trying to eat lean
earlier in the day so i just reheated
some of the chicken bowl and ate the
salmon and also didn't eat much of the
mashed potatoes because of the chicken
bowl
and that's and that's that dude so
postmates you can't win against me dude
you can't win against me
you cannot
cooper don't hit the [ __ ] camera yes
cooper hit the camera and it shook a
little bit but it's all good cooper stay
there forever
anyway dude
it's all good we're having a good time i
feel a little bit better now i got some
good food in my system i was sad today
and now i'm just chilling and i'm at a
five out of ten not like i was out of
three
um so that's good
uh
i i posted that thing that about the
huge the hugh jackman dream i had i i
[ __ ] went to zany island again last
night and uh actually this morning i
wake up at like eight and i take a zany
uh .25 it's all prescribed dude i don't
take drugs somebody's like somebody
wrote a thing uh hey you're not sober if
you're taking bro
where you been
where have you been
um
so i uh so i took a [ __ ] .25 which is
nothing and even though it's nothing
still fell asleep
dreamt of tom hanks what's going on dude
i'm not even bullshitting i dreamt of
tom hanks dude what is going on
what's going on
what's going on with the [ __ ]
alprazolem
doctors
what's going on with the alprazolam
scientists
what are you doing to my [ __ ]
yeah we'll make this good we'll make the
i know how well we'll do we'll make him
dream of celebrities
we'll make the leah dream of celebrities
tom hanks had some secrets i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was but he had some
secrets in my dream i couldn't remember
i woke up and i was like god damn i
gotta go stop going to bed island the
last time i went to zany island was a
week before i did the pot when i did the
podcast last time and i went you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to go to
[ __ ] zanny island again on the on the
the next podcast i do if i dream i swear
to god if i dream of like kenneth braun
or some [ __ ] i'm going to start snorting
it because this is i don't understand
what's going on
um
so i don't understand what's [ __ ]
going on man but it's crazy it's not
even i'm not even taking a whole zen i'm
not even taking a whole there's a
[ __ ] zanzibar dude
um
yeah
i don't get it
but i've been uh so so i posted the
video of me talking about hugh jackman
you know it was on my last podcast but i
also posted the video on my instagram
and
uh
i got everyone was talking about why do
you drink arrowhead you [ __ ] weirdo
what's wrong with arrowhead what what is
it what's did i i googled it and there's
nothing wrong like what are people are
like you [ __ ] people were like some
people were like mad i'm like what did
they like culture appropriate some [ __ ]
there was nothing on it it was just like
arrowhead
it's like the fifth worst or best i
don't even water i don't i don't read
the [ __ ] it's like it was fine i looked
at the headlines arrowhead's fine dude
it's fine water's water as long as it's
not dasani or [ __ ] um
aquafina them shits are terrible
it's so bad it tastes like pennies
it's so bad dude
and i'm not even a water snob dude
i'm not i drink arrowhead i'll kill
arrowhead evian give me hand me whatever
smart water they say smart water's bad
i'll [ __ ] handle it all dude
i'll handle it all
but people were upset that i was
drinking arrowhead and guess what that
makes me want to do get more [ __ ]
arrowhead
that's right dude
so now i'm glugging
many bottles of arrowhead
um
and another thing that people are
talking about and this is what i want to
post i want to posit this to uh you guys
because i really didn't understand this
i this is something i just learned when
i wake up because i asked my buddy the
other day when i when you i said when
you wake up
when do you do you wake up and open your
eyes
sounds very poetic but i said
when you wake up do you open your eyes
and he's he was like um he's british
he's like um
i don't know um i guess well
i don't know i kind of just like lay
there i guess the first thing i do is i
open my eyes and then um
i don't look at my phone because i like
to wait like an hour after like i get up
to look at the phone so
um
i guess i opened my eyes and i kind of
look around and
i just kind of like close them maybe a
little bit if i want to get more sleep
um but then i kind of keep them open and
i was like
really and he said yeah yeah i reckon i
do
and i was like
wow
because in the video that i'm explaining
to you the one that i posted on
instagram it's six minutes long and i'm
telling a story about my dream and my
eyes are closed the whole time
when i wake up
i don't open my eyes
okay i don't do it it's my body my
choice i wake up i let my mind wake up
first and i keep my [ __ ] eyes closed
dude because i'm not a [ __ ] ass that's
like oh my brain's up so what's up dude
who the [ __ ] that's so to me to wake up
and just be like all right what's going
on dude i'm not ready to start the day
just because you woke me up brain
i'm gonna get up when i want
all right so i wake up i keep my eyes
closed and i keep them closed i keep
them closed
for a long time
and in that six minute video my eyes
were closed the whole time and people
were like who tells a story for six
minutes with their eyes closed and then
i found out that people don't like wake
up and just kind of like chill people
wake up and open their eyes
like not even for like two minutes
that's [ __ ]
communist behavior
that's ludicrous
who would it what do you want to play
you know what i mean just waking up like
bing
hello my daddy hello hello my ragtime
gal send me i cut out too
what are you michigan j frog dude that's
weird okay open your eyes when you wanna
when you wake up
so yeah i [ __ ] keep my eyes closed as
[ __ ] for a long time
i just who who
are other people on my team with this
i don't really care i'm not gonna look
for your answers
i don't know man
that that that freaked me out am i doing
something wrong
nah
speaking of eyes dude i did the vin
scully thing the other day on my podcast
did you see the picture he tweeted of
his [ __ ] eye i almost don't even want
to call attention to it because he's
like seriously like a week away from
just like peacing out
um
he looks like somebody in star wars like
you know and he's just like like the
emperor or the guy or whatever the [ __ ]
whoever that was where you're like wow
he's really old
and uh i love vince gully like great and
it's awesome that he's doing it but he
tweeted a picture of his [ __ ] eye
pulled the eyelid down and he [ __ ]
took such a close picture of it
and uh
i don't know if he meant to like text it
or whatever to somebody
but he [ __ ] tweeted it bro when i'm
85 i hope i'm doing [ __ ] like that
because i bet he just doesn't give a
[ __ ]
but he's like i didn't mean to i
actually didn't mean to tweet the
picture of that bump on the inside of my
eye
side retired
i actually didn't mean vinskully is it
for those who don't know the dodgers
announcer i actually meant to text that
picture in an email to my eye doctor to
my ear nose and throat doctor but
instead i put it on twitter
swinging a miss
long fly ball oops tweeted my eye
ball four he walks the first
but it looks bad dude but but then i was
like wow maybe it looks bad because he's
old and he's unhealthy but then i i went
and i took a picture of close to my eye
dude i look like [ __ ] trash
my eye was close as [ __ ] and i looked
bad too dude what up vince scully we're
both announcers to the dodgers side
retired
singing
um
anyway uh
but god i just want to do that baseball
[ __ ] impression all day long when i
start doing it i just oh i just all day
long want to be like a weak and tired
kirk gibson steps up to the plate
long fly ball deep into the parking lot
passing the parking lot over a shaky's
pizza they've got great pizza there
every time i go i eat at least half the
pie over the shakies into the backyard
of a neighbor i happen to know them into
the pool the balls wet and a home run
um
so he tweeted a picture of his eye dude
everyone go out there and start tweeting
pictures of your eye
and and then hashtag it i stand with vin
it's vin scully not vince
culley
weird
um
the only two vins i know are him and vin
diesel
i don't know any other vince
nothing is stronger than family
the only thing stronger than missiles or
bad guys is
family
give me a [ __ ]
wife beater
and let me lean up against the car like
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything and
take the shot
that'll be the poster side retired
um so yeah
god man
uh
why are more people go with why don't
they go with vin who else is named vin
yeah i know it's vincent but it's but
like he goes with vince
he goes with vin rather
um
but the world's going going mad dude i
don't know if it has anything to do with
vince scully's eye i don't think that
i know his [ __ ] name is vincent dude
one fires like it's vincent you know
that i know that dude
it's like but it's like
i freaking uh
what's up with [ __ ] stupid sponsored
stories on every website for real dude
like you go to like every every website
has it you'll go on like
whatever spin magazine.com or whatever
and it'll be like
the the drummer from [ __ ] smash mouth
eats nine pieces of bubble gum
every time he wants bubble gum and
you're like oh [ __ ] okay
this [ __ ] one
on
what was the thing it was from it says
finance boulevard
what is this finance boulevard sponsored
ad
this i don't even understand
what this article could be i didn't read
it and i don't understand
who would click on it
sincerely even from a what the [ __ ]
point standpoint
this is the title the title of the
[ __ ] article mark ruffalo's son is
probably one of the most handsome men
that ever existed
okay right now i got to google how first
of all how old is mark ruffalo's son
how old
is
mark ruffalo
son here we go
top hit
about 20 years google says all right
okay mark ruffalo son is probably one of
the most handsome men that ever existed
i'm looking at a picture
of mark ruffalo what's his name keane
ruffalo
here we go images
fine looking
no i mean
a guy walks into a coffee shop i don't
register i realize i'm a guy and i'm a
heterosexual male guy walks in the
coffee shop oh there's a guy that's me
the title
mark ruffalo's son is first of all i've
said this before i swear to god the word
probably should never be in a title if
you don't know for sure something don't
be writing about it
only write about [ __ ]
he's sure of
it's like all this [ __ ] like new york
times will be like
[ __ ] uh this medication may link to
report it when you know
it's not news
so why is it in the news
so annoying dude
cancer may be linked to is it or not
that's like when it [ __ ] when they do
it on
tonight on the news of the left is
broccoli bad for you find out tonight at
11 and you're like tell me now
cause i'm about to eat broccoli for
dinner
i just wanted to show up and be like hi
this is the news at 11
and about that broccoli thing no
the [ __ ] set goes dark and they're
just talking to each other quietly
i dude i hated watching that [ __ ]
whenever
like a talk show would go dark and the
[ __ ] commercial break would happen
they would talk to i was wondering what
they said i always want to know what
they said on jay leno or [ __ ] david
letterman or cono o'brien and then i was
the guy on the couch once
and then it cuts to the [ __ ] and conan
leans over and he just says that was
good i said oh yeah it was good cool
yeah it's good that's all you [ __ ]
say just so you know that's all you say
you don't ever have some [ __ ] heart
hitting [ __ ] issues or talk about some
[ __ ] that matters
one time i apologize i said i was like
i'm sorry i meant to [ __ ] do the
thing with the thing i was like oh it's
all good it's all fun hey it's all good
and i'm like oh yeah these guys don't
give a [ __ ] they're rich as [ __ ]
it was him and andy [ __ ] richter
scale
remember that [ __ ] song
[Music]
no you don't
but yeah dude
i've been watching the show lego masters
on hulu dude i didn't really even mean
to put it on
uh
i like will arnett guy's cool
you know he's a tall drink of water like
myself and he's got a really a good
voice
i put this show on lego masters and it
was about this
it's about the greatest guys in the
country making legos and they all
compete with each other and i'm like
dude how has this not been this is so a
show that would be on in like the
[ __ ] 80s that they would remake you
know what maybe it is even i don't even
know if it is or not anyway it's on hulu
now it's on fox i think and uh
they show it on hulu and i i was like
let me just see what this is all about
because it was on my home page
sucker got suckered in by the colors of
legos
and i played it and they [ __ ] just
started
it that shit's rip roaring dude the
show's good
and now i'm gonna get legos dude i can't
get him yet because cal could choke on
him but when cal is old enough i'm gonna
get legos dude
congratulations legos you did it and in
the show they say don't say legos it's
lego the plural of lego is lego like
it's [ __ ] deer or some [ __ ] and it's
not dude i say it's not you made up the
[ __ ] word i say no i'm making up the
word
you just cause you if i make up a word
you could say how say however you want
right it's not in the dictionary i mean
it is now but just because you [ __ ]
made it and it's the company lego and
the plural of lego is lego
dude i'm not going to be out because
here's what guy i'm not going to be
the guy out there saying lego
and most and most people be like
you mean legos i i'm not going to be the
guy that's like you know actually the
the pluralization is um it's actually
lego yeah
lego pluralization
is actually lego left we forget but um
just makes me laugh and people out there
pluralizing it they're not realizing
that that would show ownership
um
and in the show they're like
the lego guys are doing the legos
and they were like yeah only dorks say
legos
hey guy
untuck your shirt
so many of the [ __ ] people on the
thing are twins too and of course they
are
because twins are weird
dude twins are so [ __ ] weird why do
we act like they're not
dude we're just cool with twins come on
get the [ __ ] out of here i was friends
with a guy for a whole [ __ ] semester
in in in high school dude a whole
semester and i was sitting i was on the
group table with him man there were five
chairs to a table i sit across from the
dude
and as i'm sitting across from the dude
he walks in also
and i [ __ ] i i thought i was in the
matrix and the matrix didn't even happen
yet they didn't even have that movie yet
the watowski brothers were probably 10.
and i almost had a [ __ ] conniption i
couldn't understand what was happening
dude
he was sitting here and he also walked
in
for a split second then i realized they
were twins but the guy never told me
i was sitting across from him at his
[ __ ] group table he never told me he
has twitch i said oh what the oh my god
that's what and i was like that's you
and he was like oh yeah i'm a twin i was
like you're just gonna [ __ ] let me
sit here for half a semester and not
tell me that you got
talking about your brother like he's
like he's not the spitting image of you
twins are weird as [ __ ] man so they got
to grab legos sometimes because they
can't have friends like we have friends
you know
when you're young dude and you're solo
and you're rolling on your dolo and
you're killing it and you're trying to
figure out who you are by yourself
that's kind of attractive because it's a
mystery you know
you got a brother maybe yeah i got a
brother i got a sister you know maybe i
don't know growing up in the streets of
new jersey is tough right
yeah what's your name milton what's your
name chris all right dude let's link up
we didn't know each other since birth
since the second we was born and then
you meet twins and they're all like
knowing each other from the second they
were born
all about each other it's weird as [ __ ]
looking like each other
and then one of them has to die and the
other one has to cry extra hard
because like basically it's like
watching you die
ah dude i don't even want to get into it
[Laughter]
god damn thank god i'm not a twin it is
the only time it's fun to be a twin
when
you're like five
you know
you get to do jokes and [ __ ]
hey it's not really me it's my brother
oh really yup haha [ __ ] that was me cuz
i always wear that hat
then when you're like [ __ ] 40
it actually probably sucks because
when you get older the what happens is
one of them even if you're identical one
of them just
essentially becomes the ugly one right
the uglier version which is like
horrible for that person and they gotta
act like it's not but like the one gets
a little bit fatter or maybe they're
more pear-shaped
and the first one's like got better hair
that would suck to be that twin that
those twins honestly at that point once
it's distinguished that one is
definitely the uglier one
the uglier one should be like yo man you
got this you got this i'm oh and they
gotta move to like germany or some [ __ ]
you can't just be hanging around in the
same city as your [ __ ] better looking
twin
do you know what i'm talking about
yo man or if you're the handsome tweed
you gotta be like twin you gotta be like
hey man i got this bro you gotta move
you gotta move over to [ __ ] you gotta
move to germany man
they don't really care uh how you look
as much as they do in america you see in
germans right
plus you you don't have blonde hair so
you'll stand out a little bit
um
so i was watching lego master jesus
christ i got way off track
a lot there's twins on there and there's
father-son duos brother sister super
cute like that they they're you know
they're like in their 20s just super
cute that they've had their whole lives
playing the [ __ ] and then there it was
like season two there's only two seasons
but there were i couldn't believe there
were no asians on the first season does
that sound like something that [ __ ]
asians would bang at it's just legos you
think they'd be making [ __ ] dragons
and [ __ ] just like killing it with legos
these guys make incredible [ __ ] dude
um
like transforming [ __ ] with motors like
who's this into legos it's insane dude
you ever [ __ ] play legos
like seriously like not just like get a
little like oh hey it's a sheep it comes
in a box it's 19 pieces you put it
together but like a [ __ ] town and
[ __ ]
first of all they're four hundred and
eighty dollars
you can't get like even you get like two
two dogs with collars with you know or a
a [ __ ] you can get like a lego chair
and it's literally like 42
or some [ __ ] that big
they have everything lego anything that
exists it's also a lego
which is crazy and it's so [ __ ]
expensive dude
but have you ever seen guys that do like
a whole town it's like what are you
doing get a puzzle like a [ __ ] real
person
get a puzzle
but these guys kill the [ __ ] kill it
with the legos dude
they made dragons that do this and like
one guy did it uh
an eagle that does this that doesn't
only flap his wings but they flap twice
they like come down and then like that
and like it [ __ ] flaps like this and
i'm like how do you even do that dude
he's like jesus christ with the legos
so yeah man
i don't know how does something become
so [ __ ] popular man
there was a whole episode on the star
wars [ __ ] with the legos
also dude this is the [ __ ] that's
hysterical to me for real
dude you're looking at the producer
credits brad pitt is a producer on lego
masters
like i love
how
funny is that dude i love that like
when you're a superstar
you could just be like
you know be a good idea
you know
and you're just like everyone's looks
like this
what
you have a good idea if you had like a
lego show or something like that and
they're like we're on it we got it we
got a treatment all right we got did you
just say legos we got a treatment brad
pitt
where is it oh we're getting it we're
getting it write it up now write it up
now we're good we're just 20 she's 20
minutes away
so here's the show
uh people compete and they do legos
brad pitt's like yeah we should [ __ ]
sell it or something like
fox
just leaning up against a [ __ ] old
truck
you make a lego show or something you
know
can i get paid for that
yeah yes
yes mr pitt yes
yeah man get guys just building legos
and [ __ ] you know
just eating a [ __ ] eclair
just with only a shirt on yeah make a
[ __ ] lego show get get producers on
it i won't have a [ __ ] thing to do
with it just put my name on it
dude it's so funny that brad pitt is a
producer on lego masters
wow unreal
i want to do that [ __ ] just [ __ ] make
some [ __ ] show it's a good show by
the way i'm not knocking the show but
just be like
yeah dude i wanna i always wanted to get
to that level of fame where you were
just like
man aren't [ __ ] uh
like ice road truckers you know like i
get there's drama in it but who the [ __ ]
knew
before ice road truckers
right
like whoever the producer was was a high
power producer i'm sure in reality tv
and like heard of ice road truckers and
read up on it and then was like we
should make an eye sort of trucker show
and they just paid attention to him
because he was a high level producer not
because they knew that iso truckers were
dope
which i guess gets good content
because you got to have a guy being like
trust me trust me this works
but that's how it all trickled on down
to shows like lego masters which happens
to be a good show
[Laughter]
but it's like how are they [ __ ] doing
this also i'm a firm believer that
people will literally watch anything you
put in front of them and i mean people i
don't mean a person right if you're
sitting there with your girl or your guy
and you're like hey i'm gonna put this
on and they might be like i don't like
that [ __ ] turn that off but people
as a as a not only the country but the
world they'll watch anything you put in
this is why people are like oh you're
gonna make [ __ ] james bond movie now
with a black woman that's gonna ruin the
franchise watch people are like it's not
sustainable
it is sustainable it doesn't matter it
doesn't [ __ ] matter dude
well why would you make this [ __ ]
person uh
a gay character when it hasn't been a
gay character the whole time because
people will watch
[ __ ]
anything dude they will watch
anything
ratings don't go down they just [ __ ]
keep happening
there's too many people it doesn't
matter they make piss-poor [ __ ]
throw it in the [ __ ] movies and
people just
go
they stream
do you know why because it's on that's
why that's it
people are always trying to crack the
code you can make [ __ ] anything and
people will watch it
case in point
you're watching this [ __ ] right now dude
i'm a lunatic
i'm out here dressed like a goddamn
coach
telling you to go medium and sometimes
stay out
and you guys are eating it up
i'm pissed poor baby
timing of this really got [ __ ] up but
here we go
[Music]
i'm piss piss-poor and you're eating it
up
liked it even though it took too long
couldn't find the key map yes dude love
it when i can't find the key map
need a separate computer with a kid i'm
a computer dude i can't ever say
computer without thinking of that old gi
joe [ __ ]
we're breaking records out here with the
[ __ ] jeremy renner [ __ ]
and that rips
people will watch anything bro they'll
watch anything you ever turn on [ __ ]
tlc you ain't learning [ __ ] dude
to have a show on grass they don't care
or [ __ ] food network how many [ __ ]
shows can you watch about preparing
meatballs
remember paula [ __ ] dean or whatever
everyone was like oh my god she said
that edward when she said the n-word i
was like
yeah why hasn't she been look at her
and listen to the way she talks
she's always a step away from saying
that
she'll just be like look at that just
drizzle all that on there
just drizzle everything was drizzled
doesn't even matter what it is just
drizzle it on there you're like they're
car keys just drizzle them on there
just drizzle those car keys what are
those cadillac car keys drizzle that
just drizzle out on the top of that
cannoli look at that look at those car
keys on that cannoli
what just drizzle it
[ __ ] black people whoa
dude paul the dean do it no [ __ ] man
no [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] man she was drizzling everything
man
look at that pork loin look at that just
drizzle that what is that oh just the
new what are you drizzling on there oh
just the nearest thing that i grabbed
just the nearest thing oh look at oh
it's actually kitty litter i would just
drill just drizzle it on there look at
that just drizzle that right on that
pork loin got kitty litter right on
there
she was so sexual the way she did it too
like you could if you just closed your
eyes and listened to paula deen when she
wasn't saying the n word you could
actually just it sounded like maybe she
was like in the mood
oh my god look at that wow this is paula
dean close your eyes oh my god look at
that look how big that is wow look at it
just come out like that look at that oh
that looks tasty that did you close your
eyes that's paula deen is she [ __ ] or
cooking
here's the game show i like to call
paula dean [ __ ] her cooking
round one oh my god look at that oh my
god wow what is that oh geez look at how
big that is that looks delicious which
one was it
turns out she was cooking
here's round two paula dean cooking her
[ __ ] round two here we go oh my god
look at that oh wow it's small but it's
look at that just taste it oh it still
tastes like it should look at that wow
oh my god look at the way it brushes up
against that on there look at that
which one was it up
round two cooking that was paula dean
cooking it's been two cookings did you
guess [ __ ] yet wasn't that you didn't
know though did you round three here we
go oh my god look at the way that is
look at that oh my god look at the way
it comes out like that put it back in
for a little bit longer oh yeah oh my
god whoops put it in too long whoa you
put it in too long oh my god did you
take it out quick enough which one was
it cooking you didn't know did you round
four here we go oh my god oh jesus look
at that oh jesus oh my god whoops got
some in my eye oh my what is that taste
that oh my god that tastes good let me
put in my bud
oh my god not too far ow oh god oh my
god did you come in my butt
that one was [ __ ]
so
thanks for playing paul dean is she
drizzle that up in my butt
drizzle those keys in my butt
oh my god i've been [ __ ] kitty
litter for a week he [ __ ] me good
well there's a quote i didn't know i was
going to say when i woke up
drizzle that kitty litter out of my butt
i've been drizzling kitty litter out of
my butt for a week now he [ __ ] me good
wow you know dude talk about sensation
oh man
so we have a good time on this dude i
gotta [ __ ] cut cause i'm too hot i
wanna put on a [ __ ] cooler
breeze your outfit i'll be back in a
second
sorry guys it gets [ __ ] hot in here i
need to put something a little bit
cooler on um anyway you can go get this
merch go medium and sometimes stay out
and get it at crystallia.com and oh my
god drizzle all that merch up in my butt
[Music]
oh my god drizzle that crew neck t-shirt
up in my butt
um how many shows can you watch on
[ __ ] the cooking channel for real i
when i got divorced
when when uh when i got divorced and my
wife left where i lived
i was in the apartment and i was in my
apartment and i left on the cooking
channel
[ __ ]
for months i left it on for months
and uh i didn't turn it off i would
leave the house i'd come back i'm sure
my electricity bill was higher but
whatever it kept me comfort so that's
why i watched the home the cooking
channel but who watches that also more
than if they're not depressed as [ __ ]
you know what i mean
you're watching someone cook and i get
it it's good something's good no hook in
i'll watch [ __ ] alton brown by the
way how much does alton brown look like
a guy who goes to the strip club and
does this
dude alton brown is
[ __ ]
dude
dude he's always like
hi chefs you know what i mean
he's always like well in here i have my
little recipes and what i do is
is alton brown a cook what's going on
here dude guy fieri [ __ ] uh uh what's
the guy's name jim battlefield the one
that i was on with
who's that guy
the guy that i did the show with
bobby flay not jim battlefield
uh beat bobby flay i was on beat bobby
flay uh bobby flay guy fieri the
contessa the barefoot contessa whatever
the [ __ ] that's so weird that she's the
barefoot contact i don't know why they
call it barefoot i guess she doesn't
wear shoes when she [ __ ] uh cooks
oh my god drizzle those shoes off my
feet i don't want those on but paula
dean all these people their show
immediately immediately
you know they're a cook
alton brown what are ya is that his name
even i gotta [ __ ] make sure that
that's the right guy it is what are you
dude what are you you're just a host or
what do you cook
do you cook because i've never seen this
dude talk about it like he does dude he
[ __ ] comes straight from the strip
club i swear to god i swear to god if i
if alton brown doesn't come
directly to work from the [ __ ]
morning shift at the strip club then i
don't know people okay do you understand
what i'm telling you
and and this comes from a guy dude
one time
i was with one of my ex-girlfriends
and we were having an argument about who
knows people better
and i said okay
pick anyone pick anyone that you see in
your eyesight and i will tell you
something specific about that person and
this isn't a lie dude
we were at the grove
okay a lot of people she could have
picked anyone she pointed to this dude
that was sitting on the fountain and
eating sandwich eating a sandwich by
himself and she said okay that guy and i
said i bet that that guy [ __ ] makes
his own furniture and [ __ ] and he's got
like pieces in his house that he made
and she was like that's ridiculous
that's so specific and i said pick
anyone
and [ __ ]
i'll be specific about it that's as
specific as you get right and she said
yep i said all right you want to go
[ __ ] ask him go ask him
and she says all right she gets up walks
over the guy sitting on the couch
fountain has a conversation with him
comes back and she's while she's walking
back she's going like this
and she says walking up to me do you
know that guy and i said no and she says
come on i said for real i don't know him
why and she said well it said he said i
asked him if he makes his own furniture
and he said well it's not like he has a
[ __ ] furniture company and [ __ ] or
like but yeah he's got like he put toge
he made his couch and like he made other
pieces of furniture and i laughed my
[ __ ] ass off i was surprised too i
didn't know i was so good at it but i am
dude so i'm telling you alton brown goes
to morning shifts at the strip club and
i'm also telling you there's nothing
[ __ ] wrong with that
if alton brown hasn't eaten at the strip
club i don't know people
what does he do dude
i bet he's the [ __ ] laughing stock of
everybody on the [ __ ] food the guys
every time he does something it lasts 15
seasons and i think it's because it
always just does fine like it's so funny
he's not a star i mean he is a star but
he's not like guy fieri
he's not like guy oh sorry fieri
no you know
people were saying you're saying it
wrong
no no
oh who am i chris
[Music]
um
so yeah dude
but alton brown dude
he looks like he would have been a dick
in middle school too god damn i [ __ ]
know people man i swear to god i know
people if he didn't [ __ ] give
[ __ ] wedgie and tell people
lies in middle school then i then i
don't know people dude
then i'm lying about that furniture
maker story
but i'm not
i think that that kind of stuff that
happens even though it's good is bad for
a guy like me because that's how i
become a dick that's how somebody
becomes a dictator
for real
i i feel like dictators are guys who
were playing blackjack and they they
know not to hit on having 18 but they do
anyway and get three is more than the
normal person and then they're like i
could rule a country
do you know what i'm saying
we're breaking records with the renter
sting
this is the most we've ever done
and honestly i'm happy about that
how do you feel about it
no problem that ain't no problem
i [ __ ] love it
anyway
there's
there's alton
brown american tv personality
he's just a oh i guess he's a chef but
that's third
alton
crawford brown jr is an
american television personality food
show presenter
chef author actor cinematographer and
musician
and strip frequent
strip club goer
um
yeah dude
all right i think that's good for now
probably
is it
okay
you guys are great thank you very much i
had a good time and uh look man
get in the face of that like button and
you give them a stern talking to
you do that for us and the and the cult
that we are in the congratulations cult
that we are in and we got to get to that
log captain
and you look at that subscribe button
and you take your sunglasses off and you
give them a mean stare
like they cut you off earlier and they
might recognize you
and if you want to you saunter on over
to that bell notification number
button not number belt notification
button and you just hip check it do it
you hit check it you keep walking you
see if they want to fight that's what
you do due to all those three things
because it helps our algorithm it helps
us grow
all right
and if you're not making friends in the
comments you ain't doing [ __ ] dude
leave a comment below
and say hey what's up
i'm from kentucky where's everybody else
from or say some [ __ ] like [ __ ] that
show the walking dead anybody with me
make friends meet people off your hatred
for the show the walking dead
at least the later seasons
hey guys that was the episode for
youtube uh if you want to catch the rest
of the episode head on over to my
patreon that is patreon.comchristalia
and uh you can go and watch the rest of
this episode and the rest of every other
episode that has happened um and also
there are other episodes that aren't
even released to youtube um i think
there's probably like [ __ ] there's a lot
there now but um
and then there's also uh behind the
scenes stuff that i post sometimes and
there is also another segment that i do
called review mode you get to look at
that there's a lot of extra stuff going
on over on my patreon so go ahead and
check it out
patreon.comcrystalia thanks for
listening
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
hey boys welcome to the next episode of
congratulations